please welcome
comedy legend beautiful woman and my
dear friend molly shannon
by the way you look
so beautiful
you look so pretty drew
oh molly i wait do i stand here i love
you nervous so much
why don't you come take a seat over here
they say it's the better lighting so i'd
rather
um you know molly and i uh we made
really close friends on the movie and we
continued that friendship and i was
always able to talk to you about
life and family and friendship and the
real stuff that's important between
girlfriends yes drew that's so sweet and
women need other women and it's so nice
and you know i feel the same way about
you we had a great time making that
movie and you were a real
role model for me on set
i really learned how to behave in show
business from drew barrymore
yeah
you taught me
yeah
well you know
that makes me happy because you were
also
my velcro
when i would go to saturday night live
which was my most important institution
i first hosted in 1982 at seven years
old i'm still the youngest host
i'm like seriously gonna be so happy and
slightly resent any child that takes
that uh
that title away from me i'll be like i'm
so happy for you
[Laughter]
um
and of course my favorite segment on the
show was
talk show
[Applause]
and true
true was so funny i actually put it on
my instagram because it is my favorite
dog show she played michael trulio yeah
it's one of my favorite performances you
you embraced michael trulia now i want
to quickly talk to you about
the show
of the year
white lotus
i
um
i wanted to do a really good job because
i knew it was a really good part and we
shot it in maui we all lived at the four
seasons it was a dream job i got to
bring my kids because they were in
remote school
and they would i would i'd be like i'm
gonna shoot a scene in the lobby and
they would like snorkel and then walk
back with their gear on and be like hi
molly hi mike and then it was it was the
greatest job for a mom now you have
another show
on hbo max and you are a talk show host
in this amazing series that it's going
into season two it's wildly popular it's
called the other two it's on hbo max
take a look do you have a sad grumpy
friend who needs a pick-me-up then enter
them to win a shopping spree with me pat
sponsored by mastercard but paid for by
me personally great number 13.
brookie we're really scheduling a lot of
these but don't forget that i have
lisa's son's wedding in ohio next month
keep reading do you like weddings when a
chance to come to my friend lisa's son's
wedding in ohio next month oh with me
pat
how do you feel playing a talk show
house i love playing a talk show host
it's so fun so i get i'm pretending to
do what you do in real life
and um i have to say i love it
[Music]
you